what we're going to do in this video is
talk about acidity and in particular
we're going to talk about the pH scale
now the first question is what does pH
stand for and it turns out that there's
some debate why we have this lowercase P
here we know why we have the H and some
people will tell you it stands for power
of hydrogen the capital H for hydrogen
some people will say it's the potential
of hydrogen some people say it's the
capacity for hydrogen you might say
capacity doesn't start with a P but if
you go into Latin it can but what do all
of these things mean and why do we care
about hydrogen so much well it turns out
that hydrogen and in particular a
hydrogen positive ion anion is just a
positively charged molecule that a
hydrogen ion can play a major role in
how acidic or basic something is and so
the pH scale you're going to see it go
from zero all the way to 14 with of
course seven in the middle and something
that is towards the left something that
is less than seven is considered acidic
and so if you have a pH near zero that
is highly highly highly acidic while
something to the right is considered
basic and something in the middle is
considered neutral and another term for
basic you'll sometimes see is alkaline
an alkaline actually comes from arabic
for alkali which was the word that
ancient Arab chemists use for a compound
that happens to be very basic by our
modern definition but what does it mean
to be acidic and what does it mean to be
basic and once again how does that
connect with hydrogen ions well it turns
out and I'm not going to go in depth in
this video is that things that are
acidic tend to have lots of hydrogen
ions and while things that are basic
tend to react react with these hydrogen
ions there's other definitions for what
it means to be an acid or a base and
we'll go into depth in chemistry class
on
but this is why it's connected with the
term pH now what are examples of things
that are acidic well you see it on this
chart right over here here we're going
in the vertical direction things in our
everyday life that are quite acidic a
lot of fruits are quite acidic for
example lemons and grapefruits and
orange juice are quite acidic they're at
the low end of the scale and some of the
tell-tale signs for acidity is that if
you were to drink it or eat it that it
would have this kind of sharp sour taste
to it while if you go to the other end
of the spectrum things that are basic
these would be things like bleaches an
ammonia solution and we can even go
super basic to liquid drain cleaner and
these are going to have more of a slimy
texture to it in fact even soap is quite
basic and of the basic things that you
could eat you might have a bitter taste
associated with it but to be clear I
really don't recommend eating or
drinking anything that is either a
highly basic or highly acidic and the
reason is is that things that are at the
extreme of the pH scale so things that
are either extremely basic or things
that are extremely acidic like battery
acid or hydrochloric acid because they
can they're so reactive they will damage
you they were if you pour it on your
skin it will damage you if you died if
you ingest it it will damage your cells
and it can even kill you so don't try to
taste things to see whether their acid
or basic and if you do try to make sure
that they're closer to this middle range
of our pH scale so I've talked a lot
about things that are acidic or basic
but also what's interesting is things
that we consider to be neutral so our
blood for example is quite neutral and
this is something that doctors might
measure because if your pH in your blood
gets a little bit too high or a little
bit too low that can cause some serious
problems sea water is pretty close to
being neutral milk is not that far off
of being neutral now with that said in
order to read the pH scale appropriately
or to appreciate the differences in
acidity and basicity it's important to
realize that it is not a linear scale so
for example
that has a pH of 8 is not twice as basic
as something that has a pH of 4 it turns
out when you go from one level of our P
scale to the other you are going up in
basicity say going from a pH 4 to a pH
of 5 by a factor of 10 and so comparing
something with a pH of 4 to a pH of 8
the thing with the pH of 4 would be ten
hundred thousand ten thousand times more
acidic or you could say the thing with
the pH of eight is ten hundred thousand
ten thousand times more basic so I'll
leave you there keep a look out when
people talk about pH balanced or blood
pH and we're also as we study more and
more biology we're going to talk about
how pH might influence some biological
reactions and especially once you get
into chemistry pH will inform us what
type of reaction is likely to happen